I'm the only Christian that went after
him publicly and and that blew my mind
because I listen to Ben Shapiro on Joe
Rogan you know from from a Jewish point
of view where we don't believe in the
Divinity of Christ I think that there
you can make an argument that the the
gospels which were written he was just a
prophet in signific no no no we don't
even believe he was a prophet what do
you think he was what do you guys I mean
I what I what do I think he was
historically I think he was a Jew who
tried to lead a revolt against the
Romans and got killed for his trouble
just like a lot of other at that time
who were crucified for trying to lead
revolts against the Roman and got killed
for their trouble talk about how Jesus
Christ was um a common criminal and was
killed for rebelling against Rome which
is this insane statement and then my
Muslim friend would say Jesus peace be
upon him and I was like huh that kind of
made it through the programming and that
goes into to my question do you get
offended when we say Jesus peace be upon
him that you know when we you know when
I tell you I proudly I'm very proud and
excited to say I love Jesus obviously we
can get the elephant out of the room you
know the difference we don't believe
he's uh God okay we can we can agree to
disagree on something but I mean we love
him we love his Blessed Mother and I've
tried to I've tried to tell Christians
Muslims love and respect
Jesus not as a Son of God as we do but
they love and respect him but Jews will
spit on the ground when you say his name
that is The Godly thing to do we respect
one another The Godly thing to do is to
kill you The Godly thing is to kill me
that's right that's what the Torah says
the Torah says to kill us the Torah says
that I don't people who worship Idol
such as yourself when there is a
Sanhedrin to kill us yes okay that's
what the Torah say so we know how the
Jewish people feel about Christians yes
that you discriminate against Christians
Christians are Idol discriminate against
Tor says that Christianity is idol
worship
[Music]
two
that's you I'm a Jewish and I'm the
blessed one you are the curse you
understand why are you why are you
defending the people that will spit when
you say Jesus and then hating the people
who say I love Jesus it doesn't make
sense to me that's such a strange
relationship uh in this video also he
talks about Ben Shapiro I don't know if
you've heard of him Ben Shapiro I call
him I call him blaspheming Ben you know
why because I went after him a couple
years ago I'm the only Christian that
that went after him publicly because he
said that Jesus was a criminal a
revolutionary who deserved to be
crucified wow and I went after him and I
called him a blasphemer and now whenever
I talk about him I always call him
blaspheming Ben but do you know do you
know uh somebody who used to work at
breit Bart news which was started by uh
Netanyahu it was wow I didn't know that
oh yes yes uh Andrew Breitbart worked
closely with Yahoo to start Breitbart
News but a a man who worked at Breitbart
News said recently that when he worked
at Breitbart he
saw Israeli Massad agents
delivering information to Ben Shapiro to
put out in his
videos how did this world so Shapiro
is whether he's paid or not paid he he
is in his isra intelligence asset is an
operative there's one thing I want to I
want to add because I don't if you got
to close out I'll be quiet no go ahead
no no no keep going keep going yeah I
want to just respect your time go ahead
well okay it's your it's your show I
don't want to take over your show keep
going no keep going I'm really enjoying
talking with you okay you mentioned
earlier
anti-Semitism what is
anti-Semitism I refuse to use the word
anymore once I figured it out I don't
say it anymore is disent expressed in
the United States against policies of
the Israeli government um uh people here
are called anti-semitic what is your
response to that as an Israeli Jew well
it's a trick we always use it when from
Europe somebody is criticizing Israel
then we bring up the Holocaust when in
this country people are criticizing
Israel then there are anti-semitic and
the organization is strong and has a lot
of money and the the ties between Israel
and the American EST Jewish
establishment are very strong and they
are strong in this country as you know
they have power which it's okay they're
talented people and they have power
money and media and other things and
their attitude is Israel my country
right or wrong the
identification and they are not ready to
hear criticism
is I'm Dr and I'm so excited to be here
at the dean Center Mah which is under
renovation and I can't wait to see
what's going to come inshah there's
going to be a dawa Center there's a
Masjid there's a school an Islamic
school a gym and what we hope inshallah
we'll also have a mental health part of
this Center as well inshallah so I'm
asking you to please make sure that you
support this effort inshallah I really
hope that it spreads and really the
knowledge of Islam and people get to
know more about Muslims and Islam
through this effort
[Music]
for